bonjour à tous comme nathan vient de le
dire je m'appelle à cannes je suis
devant vous pour parler d'un sujet assez
particulier qui a fait que j'ai pu avoir
la chance d'écrire un livre qui
s'appelle en forme à le placer je suis
un ancien enfant qui a été placée c'est
à dire que j'ai été dans les services
sociaux ce que vous avez pu entendre
pour ceux qui connaissent et l'aide
sociale à l'enfance pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas ou anciennement vous
avez dû entendre le mot de la dass
j'ai fait partie du coût d'une famille
d'accueil et après par la suite d'une
mexes maison d'enfants à caractère
social et aujourd'hui je suis éducateur
spécialisé et la vie a fait que j'ai eu
plein d'opportunités parce que
dans ce type de structure j'ai eu la
chance de d'aller jusqu'au bac et de
continuer mes études et donc vous du
coup pour ce type de structure j'ai pour
eux incarné la réussite cette réussite
m'a fait avoir la possibilité de passer
des des reportages à la télévision que
j'ai fait avec différentes chaînes télé
et le dernier reportage que j'ai pu
faire
on a offert la possibilité en fait
d'écrire un livre c'est comme ça que
j'ai écrit le livre en format le placer
ce qui était une très belle expérience
et c'est pour ça que je suis aujourd'hui
devant vous pour vous expliquer un peu
cette démarche là parce que ce livre
m'a fait réfléchir à trois questions que
je me suis posée tout au long de ma vie
c'est d'où je viens qui je suis et où je
vais alors c'est des questions qui
peuvent paraître bête mais
mais au final qui ont toute leur
importance dans la progression d'un
enfant d'un adolescent et surtout de
l'adulte que vous êtes aujourd'hui
avant de d'aller plus en profondeur par
rapport à ce propos je vais vous parler
d'un truc qui est important pour moi de
quelque chose qui est vraiment une place
particulière c'est l'héritage pour vous
qui est devant moi aujourd'hui
l'héritage ça peut être un héritage
immobilier que vous allez avoir par
quelqu'un de votre famille ça peut être
des dettes pour certains ça peut être
des valeurs pour d'autres que vous allez
acquérir soin de vos parents soin de la
personne qui a l'autorité parentale ou
alors quelqu'un de votre famille pour ma
part l'héritage ça a été le placement
s'est un peu particulière je pas choisi
mais ça a été le placement dans le sens
où ma mère a été placée elle aussi dès
sa tendre enfance et que ma grand mère
aussi a été placé en termes d'héritage
ya mieux quand même je vous assure j'ai
pas gagné grand chose mais du coup ça
fait quand même un héritage sur trois
générations ce qui est très particulier
et là aujourd'hui je vous en parle assez
librement assez facilement mais ce qui a
été compliqué dans ma vie c'est que
avant de savoir tout ça j'ai dû faire
beaucoup de recherches et du coup
comprendre d'où je venais parce que je
suis né j'ai été directement placé ma
mère en fait pour vous expliquer
elle a été elle était dans la
prostitution elle a été dans de la
consommation
de drogues à la même été comme on
appelle ça un dans des go-fast et ce
genre de choses on dirait que c'est une
série netflix mais pourtant ça n'est pas
le cas c'est réellement sa vie et ma
mère est décédée très jeune et 26 ans
elle m'a mis au monde quand elle avait
17 ans et du coup à 17 ans bat pour
certaines personnes vous n'êtes pas
capable de vous occuper d'un enfant pour
ma mère c'était le cas donc très
rapidement j'ai été placée mais j'étais
à placer à un endroit très particulier
c'est à dire que ma mère en fête a été
placé dans une famille d'accueil à 17
ans et à la louer les des liens très
forts avec cette famille d'accueil
et ma mère avait un sale caractère
réellement et à la décide de faire en
sorte de me faire placer dans cette
famille d'accueil là c'est à dire que
les services sociaux s'occuper de moi à
l'aller dans le dans les différents
établissements je pouvais être placée
elle me prenait à nouveau les clairement
également mené dans cette famille
d'accueil l'a donc officiellement j'ai
été placé à un an et demi officieusement
j'étais passé à trois mois c'est à dire
que tout de suite déjà quand je vous
parle il ya peut-être potentiellement
une différence entre vous votre parcours
de vie où vous avez eu vos parents ou
autres est la mienne où j'ai été placé
j'ai commencé cette vie comme ça ce qui
est plutôt particulier et pour continuer
du coup dans cette famille d'accueil là
il y avait quatre autres enfants placés
avec moi donc ça fonctionne assez
facilement ils ont fêté un agrément qui
vous est donnée et du coup elle s'occupe
de nous il y avait aussi les autres
enfants de cette famille d'accueil là on
devait l'appeler tata cette femme qui
s'occupait de moi et son mari je devais
l'appeler tonton paraître basique on a
l'impression que c'est très familial et
c'est comme ça normalement que c'est
censé être un cocon familial sauf qu'il
ya beaucoup de différences qui ont été
faites je vous donner des exemples
plutôt plutôt concret c'est-à-dire que
vous si vous avez fait si vous faites
noël si vous avez fait noël étant plus
jeune vous avez des cadeaux aux frères
et soeurs si vous en avez on lui aussi
plein de petits cadeaux et non il ya une
différence qui était faite entre les
enfants de cette famille avec l' exemple
tout bête des jolis pieds mobile et pour
les enfants place et vous aviez la
sous-marque alors j'étais très content
d'avoir des cadeaux mais quand vous
sentez cette petite différence déjà qui
est sur un événement qui est marquant
pour l'enfance vous savez vous n'êtes
pas de cette famille là c'était pareil
pour le carnet vous étiez
alors nous dans le système familial
qu'on avait c'était si tu travailles
bien tu vas avoir un peu d'argent au
moment où tu reçois ton carnet alors il
ya pas mal de faux je me suis défoncé à
l'école pour avoir des bonnes notes
malgré certaines difficultés dans
certains cours désolé à mes anciens
profs tous ses pairs qui l'entendront
bas
et la difficulté par rapport à ça c'est
que quand je revenais avec de très
bonnes notes et que dans la famille les
enfants venaient avec de très bonnes
notes il ya des choses qui étaient mises
devant vous en évidence c'est à dire que
je me rappelle une fois qui m'a marqué
où elle m'a donné deux euros en disant
bravo tu as très bien travaillé j'avais
17 de moyenne et son petit fils qui
avait eu jusqu'à 12 ou 13 et qui a vu
son euro et c'était au même moment ce
qui a été quelque chose quand même
d'assez violent pour moi je me suis je
me défonce et au final bain
quelle est ma place dans ce dans ce
système là c'était une réalité que j'y
vais mais cette réalité là elle était
difficile à expliquer a exprimé par
rapport aux autres parce que j'avais
cette identité à moi par rapport au fait
que j'étais placé que je vivais dans
cette famille d'accueil la qui était
encore différente par rapport à
l'identité des personnes que je côtoyais
c'est à dire que quand j'allais à
l'école quand j'allais au collège vous
avez des gens entre guillemets lambda
quand il rentrait me disais bon bah je
rentre chez mon père où j'entre chez ma
mère j'ai un tel dans la famille qui va
aller en chercher moi la maison c'était
différent du coup je disais bon bah je
rentre chez tata et les gens me
demandaient pourquoi cette hâte à et
j'ai adopté certaines techniques bête
mais qui m'ont permis d'esquiver pas mal
de choses dans la vie et qui m'ont
permis d'éviter de parler d'eux d'avoir
été un enfant placé c'est à dire que
j'expliquais a largement appel à cannes
marty monde famille marty c'est un nom
de famille qui potentiellement peut
faire penser que ces espagnols en tout
cas moi c'est comme ça que je les jouais
je disais que j'étais espagnol la
famille d'accueil alors et espagnol on
allait à chaque vacances à côté de la
catalogne donc il y avait une maison de
vacances qui étaient là bas c'était
chouette hein et j'ai appris à parler
espagnol là bas et j'ai expliqué à tous
les gens qui m'entouraient que j'étais
venu en france par le biais de tata et
tonton pour avoir des diplômes français
qui étaient beaucoup plus valorisées en
espagne qu'en france évidemment j'en
savais strictement rien mais les gens
devant moi me disait ah ouais c'est
génial trop bien et donc certains
pousser un peu plus loin pour savoir qui
j'étais vraiment lisible et vas-y par
l'espagnol je pense que vous l'avez tous
et quand vous a rencontré quelqu'un qui
était bilingue ou autre et du coup je
sortais 3,80 en espagnol assez
rapidement et espagnols c'est incroyable
tout ça du coup je m'en sortais pas mal
là dessus tu es une petite techniques
que j'ai utilisées encore il ya très peu
de temps parce que ça m'a évité de
parler d'un sujet qui était sensible
pour moi parce que j'avais peur qu'on me
parle bas de qui j'étais et qui j'avais
envie yade qui j'avais envie d'être pour
revenir à cette place que j'avais dans
cette famille d'accueil la mode la de la
différence qui était faite avec les
enfants qui étaient
deux cents il y avait autre chose qui
était compliqué à vivre pour moi c'est
la place qu'on pouvait me donner quand
vous êtes enfant vous avez envie de
vivre des choses d'enfants vous êtes
adolescent vous avez envie de vivre des
choses à donner 100 étudiants vous avant
de sortir faire la fête ici on a
certains qui on a parlé thaler et c'est
plutôt bien ancrée mais juste
pour ma part quand j'étais dans cette
famille d'accueil là l'enfant que
j'étais
n'avait pas sa place c'est-à-dire qu'on
me demandait d'être un homme alors un
homme avec un grand h un homme comme
chacun peut se l'imaginer dans les
anciennes réflexion il fallait que ce
soit quelqu'un de dur quelqu'un de fort
quelqu'un de costaud il avait
interdiction de pleurer pendant des
années je n'ai plus réussi à pleurer de
ma vie je pouvais regarder le titanic je
ne pleurais pas de vent j'ai regardé le
roi lion je n'ai pas pleuré devant
malheureusement et j'avais vraiment un
blocage qui du coup avec le temps et le
travail a fait que ça s'est amélioré
mais je ne pouvais pas vraiment parce
qu'on me demandait d'être d'être un
homme avant l'âge on m'a demandé d'avoir
des responsabilités dans cette famille
par rapport aux autres enfants et par
rapport à la situation qui allait parce
qu'en fait j'ai été confronté aussi un
très rapidement
c'est un peu glauque ce que je veux dire
mais à la mort ma mère est décédée quand
j'avais 8 ans alors la première fois
qu'on m'a dit qu'elle était décédée
c'était dans un accident de camion la
deuxième fois qu'on m'a dit qu'elle
était décédée d'une overdose et la
troisième fois qu'on m'a dit qu'elle
était décédée c'était d'un assassinat
c'est quand même beaucoup de choses par
rapport à une personne qu'on considère
comme un repère
à huit ans ma mère est décédée à 9 ans
dont on est décédé c'est moi qui a
retrouvé le corps dans le jardin donc ça
faisait déjà une deuxième chose à
appréhender pour un enfant qui était
quand même pas mal costaud et quelques
années après avec 15 ans
cette fameuse tata est décédé dans mes
bras quand j'étais en espagne et du coup
cette question là encore à se dire je
suis un enfant je suis un adolescent je
suis confronté à quelque chose qui est
du cycle de la vie mais en tout cas à
cette période là qui était difficile
pour moi à gérer et savent pas comment
gérer ça je sais pas comment l'exprimer
j'avais pas comment l'extérioriser donc
j'ai gardé ce système là d'être un homme
est d'être fort et de faire face à tout
ça et cette place pour moi
elle a été
beaucoup plus difficile à vivre par la
suite c'est à dire que par la suite
cette famille d'accueil là avant qu'elle
ne décède elle se voyait mourir elle m'a
dit bon bah à cannes je me vois mourir
tu vas partir tu vas les employés
normalement on appelle ça une ex maison
d'enfants à caractère social pour ceux
qui connaissent pas en gros c'est les
foyers où vous êtes 10 à 12 gamin alors
aujourd'hui à des structures ce qui fait
quand même beaucoup plus adapté il ya
des travailleurs sociaux qui se relaient
tous les jours pour venir s'occuper
d'eux des enfants qui ont deux ans je
préfère une définition mais juste
imaginer ça pour certains vous a vu des
émissions à la télé qu'ils sont qui ne
reflète pas la réalité malheureusement
parce que c'est beaucoup plus complexe
que ça d'accompagner un enfant et un
adolescent mais voilà donc j'ai atterri
je veux dire ça j'ai atterri du coup
dans une ex et là j'ai découvert ce que
tout enfant devrait vivre c'est-à-dire
la vie j'ai pu jouer quand je voulais
j'ai pu rigoler j'ai pu manger j'ai pu
comment dire
découvrir des émissions de télé qui font
pas beaucoup réfléchir mais du coup
c'était marrant voilà j'ai découvert
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
j'ai découvert la vie en collectivité le
fait de pouvoir sortir avec des amis du
coup je me suis créé différents repères
et c'est là pour son identité pour sa
construction je trouve ça important de
parler de ça et en même temps j'étais
mélanger entre deux mondes j'avais ce
premier monde de la famille d'accueil où
j'avais mes repères qui du coup on était
un peu brisé par les décès de toutes ces
personnes là j'arrivais dans une
structure avec plein de monde et c'est
là où en fait je trouve que pour un
enfant c'est super important de devoir
s'adapter à son environnement et souvent
en demande un enfant de s'adapter et pas
l'environnement de s'adapter à l'enfant
ça c'est une question pour moi qui
m'importe aujourd'hui
c'est un autre débat mais qui est
important aussi dans cette structure là
j'ai découvert du coup beaucoup de
choses et en même temps
j'ai eu quelque chose une sorte de
révélation j'ai découvert qu'il a vécu
des maltraitances dans cette famille
d'accueil là c'est à dire que la famille
idéalisée et que j'aime et m'a fait
vivre des choses qu'on ne devrait pas
faire vivre à des enfants c'est à dire
que j'ai vécu ce qu'on appelle des
séquestrations j'ai vécu ce qu'on
appelle des violences physiques des
coups de fouet une des coups de poing
des coups de pied le fait d'être
interdit de manger de devoir être
enfermé à l'extérieur en plein hiver
voilà ce genre de choses encore
certaines sicav certaines cicatrices
pardon voilà j'ai vécu des choses qu'on
ne devrait pas vivre en tant qu'enfants
et encore aujourd'hui certains le vivent
et c'est quelque chose qui est
inacceptable
et al'inverse j'ai eu des personnes qui
ont fait partie et qui font aujourd'hui
partie intégrante de ma vie de ma
famille j'ai rencontré des gens qui sont
exceptionnelles donc j'ai plein de
petites familles mais à ce moment là
c'était difficile parce que je me suis
dit mais premiers repères que j'avais en
tant qu'enfant en tant qu'adolescent ce
qui m'a créé ma propre identité qui
avaient été brisées comment pouvoir
faire confiance à de nouvelles personnes
qui sont censés le faire comment dire
entre guillemets du bien sont censés
m'aider et m'accompagner dans cette dans
cette construction identitaire c'était
violent pour moi parce que j'avais pas
et pendant des années jusqu'à l'écriture
de ce livre qui est sorti cette année je
savais pas où était ma place c'est pour
vous dire le temps que ça mais la
réflexion que ça mais
dans tous les cas ils m'ont accompagné
là dedans ils ont été super ils ont été
géniaux ils sont bienveillants et
d'ailleurs je les remercie énormément et
c'est pour ça que j'écris lire aussi
c'était pour les remercier parce qu'ils
ont fait beaucoup beaucoup de choses
pour moi et ça m'a beaucoup aidé et à
partir de là une chose importante quand
j'ai quitté le système éducatif donc
j'avais 18 ans l'aide sociale à
l'enfance ase m'a programmé un
rendez-vous et m'a dit à cannes chez
nous coûte trop cher
voilà comment j'étais considéré c'est à
dire que moi qui n'avais pas le choix
par rapport à mon histoire familiale
la solution qui était
pour moi la meilleure pour pouvoir m'en
ressortir qu'ils étaient là l'aide
sociale à l'enfance mahdi en direct tu
nous coûte trop cher donc j'étais plus
orientées comme un être humain j'ai été
orienté comme quelqu'un qui représentait
une manne financière
c'est à dire bon tu nous coûte trop cher
la ligne x z est trop importante au
revoir quant à 18 ans enfin je vous
laisse imaginer vous vos parcours de vie
alors peut-être que certains ont vécu la
même chose
d'autres non mais imaginez vous à 18 ans
devoir se débrouiller tout seul à voir
ses études alors j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir le bac et du coup j'ai été en
fac de sport à ce moment là et j'étais
entre deux mondes d'une partie j'étais
par rapport au foyer une réussite parce
que j'avais le bac et en même temps me
disais que coûtait trop cher et que je
devais partir et de l'autre côté j'avais
ce monde réel ou en tant qu'étudiant à
18 tu vas commencer les autres études et
tu sais que tu vas devoir te débrouiller
pour réussir à payer tes études gérer
les cours et tout ce qui va tout ce qui
va avec tout ce que vous connaissez au
niveau du quotidien des étudiants ce qui
a été très difficile mais j'ai eu de la
chance d'une éducatrice qui m'a fait
passer le bafa pour ceux qui connaissent
vous travaillez des enfants dans
l'animation c'est plutôt cool vous
faites des colos vous faites des centres
de loisirs on vous découvre plein de
choses et ça m'a permis de développer un
peu mon identité professionnelle
et pour moi c'était quelque chose
d'incroyable parce que j'ai découvert
plein de choses des valeurs de la vie le
fait de devoir se lever à tel ou tel
horaire josé à l'école mais là c'était
un du coup de manière individuelle et
pour ma propre réussite mais en même
temps ça me montrer que je voulais m'en
sortir et que je voulais réussir à
m'insérer dans la société
donc j'ai passé le bafa est ce ma femme
m'a fait devenir directeur de structure
directeur de séjours de vacances m'a
fait progresser en tant que être humain
en tant qu'homme
et se bat falla grâce à une amie qui m'a
dit à cannes ben voilà tepa animateurs
étaient pas directeurs de structures
taux des éducateurs j'ai ouvert les yeux
je me suis dit ah ouais en fait c'est
peut-être ce métier là que je vais faire
je vais approfondir mes recherches mes
compétences pour accompagner au mieux
les les enfants les adolescents qui font
les adultes de demain est vraiment je me
suis dit ça alors je m'étais dit mais
moi j'ai été un gamin de foyers je peux
pas être là dedans c'est impossible et
cette question là m'a renvoyé à une
autre question que j'ai déjà entendu
c'est à dire l'héritage qu'on peut avoir
de sa famille on entend souvent parler
de des avocats qui ont des enfants qui
deviennent avocats des médecins qui ont
leurs enfants qui deviennent un médecin
à leur tour et on a ce cette question-là
par rapport à la transmission des des
familles par rapport à leurs enfants et
lorsque c'est une question super
intéressante parce que sur un plateau
télé j'ai un présentateur qui me dit en
fait vous revenez dans ce que vous avez
toujours été et il définissait comme ça
et je me suis dit mais ça n'a rien à
voir c'est un choix c'est une réflexion
c'est une question d'orientation et
d'ailleurs c'est parce que j'ai envie de
faire de ma vie plus tard j'ai d'autres
ambitions d'autres choses mais du coup
c'est une question voilà qui est super
importante pour savoir l'environnement
dans lequel vous vivez dans lequel vous
êtes
va-t-il influencer sur l'identité que
vous allez avoir personnelle et
professionnelle dans tous les cas
j'ai continué je suis devenu éducateur
spécialisé j'ai travaillé aussi en
protection enfant j'ai travaillé dans
dans le handicap dans la prévention j'ai
travaillé à l'étranger
et cette question là m'a ouvert les yeux
et m'a fait réfléchir et m'a fait
espérer à plein de choses
aujourd'hui on est tous adultes là les
uns et les autres devant nous on a un
système français où on a beaucoup de
compétences il ya des moyens il ya des
choses mais il ya aussi certaines
lacunes ça c'est une réalité d'ailleurs
comme dans plein de pays dans comme dans
plein de système mais j'envisage et
j'espère pouvoir pousser la chose ou on
améliorera l'accompagnement des enfants
et qu'on permettra à chaque enfant de
pouvoir choisir sa propre identité
personnelle et professionnelle et pour
ça j'imagine un système où on puisse
accompagner l'enfant dans des structures
qui soit adaptée à ses propres
problématiques et pour avoir des
structures qui soit adaptée à ses
propres problématiques cd réussir à
faire travailler les gens ensemble les
gens du médico-social à travailler tous
ensemble c'est à dire que les gens du
handicap puissent travailler que la
protection d'un fonds cela puisse
travailler avec la protection judiciaire
des mineurs qu'ils puissent travailler
avec d'autres systèmes et qu'on soit
tous autour d'une table et qu'on puisse
vraiment travaillé pour l'accompagnement
et qu'on arrête de m voilà plein de
barrières en termes de temporalité en
termes de dossiers il ya des choses qui
peuvent être faites et on a des
compétences en france pour ça et je suis
persuadé qu'on peut réussir à le faire
j'imagine aussi un homme un énorme
travail qui puisse être fait sur la
parentalité aujourd'hui certains d'entre
vous êtes parents d'autres non d'autres
vont le devenir d'autre part choix ou
autres ne le seront pas mais juste une
chose qui est importante être parent
c'est pas rien ce n'est pas n'importe
quoi et être parents on ne devient pas
comme ça c'est en regardant une vidéo
youtube qu'on va réussir en mai pour ça
on peut accompagner la parentalité on
peut donner des billes aux gens pour
qu'ils deviennent
les gros travail est important j'en
parle en connaissance de cause parce que
je travaille en protection enfant sur la
parentalité et je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire qui peuvent
être positifs et on peut en parler et
une dernière chose pour terminer mon
propos c'est l'attractivité de ce métier
du médico social
aujourd'hui être travailleur social on
parle beaucoup de vocations parle
beaucoup c'est un métier avec eux de
belles valeurs les gens disent aura
c'est un métier difficile c'est dur ce
que tu dois faire moi je dis que c'est
pas dur c'est beau ce qu'on fait parce
qu'on accueille la parole de l'autre on
travaille selon là où la personne allant
népal là où nous et je me dis que si on
améliore la formation des travailleurs
sociaux qu'on améliore l'attractivité au
niveau financier de ces travailleurs
sociaux là on pourra faire de belles
choses et du coup amener du monde qui
seraient intéressés dans tous les cas
voilà c'était mon propos est juste pour
terminer
mes projets plus tard tu alors j'en ai
parlé c'est de partir à l'étranger je
pars bientôt à l'étranger pour aller
découvrir juste devant d'autres méthodes
d'autres pratiques éducatives
pourquoi vous le cacher ce canada je
vais avoir froid mais ça va être kraft
cool et pour autre chose j'aimerais plus
tard ouvrir une structure qui n'existe
pas encore alors je ne sais pas encore
sous quelle thématique mais qui puisse
accueillir différents publics et
justement réfléchir à toutes ces
pratiques qu'on pourrait mettre en place
pour tous ces enfants qui ont besoin
voilà moi c'était à cames marty et je
vous remercie beaucoup de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]